(upbeat music)
- Hi,
I'm Kristof Zyskowski,
and we are in the
Environmental Science Center
next door to the Peabody Museum building
and we are in the Bird
and Mammal Collections
of the Peabody Museum.
Here,
we actually have cabinets
full of bird skins.
We have about 70% of all
bird species of the world,
represented in about 150,000 specimens.
And here,
let's look at what they are like.
So here we are in the drawer of Wrens,
specifically Cactus Wren,
and here I'm holding a specimen
collected in Tucson, Arizona
by David Parsons on 6th April, 1958.
So each specimen is a
point in time and space
and there's a description
of the internal anatomy.
These are extremely valuable
to scientists and used,
not only by scientists,
but also by artists and for
various studies of genetics
and morphology.
And the reason we have multiple
specimens of each species
is that...
It's because to do any
statistical analysis
and measurements,
you need more than one,
and you can also see
that there is variation.
Not a single bird here is
identical to the other.
We actually need to have series.
And if we move to some
species like House Wren,
where there are multiple
geographic subspecies,
you can actually see maybe
that these two are quite different.
So this one here is from
Granada Island in the Caribbean,
and this one here from Columbia,
from Santander in the Andes.
So the reason for collecting
multiple specimens
is for us to be able to
understand things like
geographic variation
and sexual and seasonal
variation in these birds.
So here we are with some
additional examples of specimens
from the Peabody Museum Collections.
So in addition to preserving study skins,
we also occasionally preserve
the entire bird in ethanol.
And these kind of anatomical
specimens can be used
for visualizing skeleton
and internal organs using
current technologies like CAT scanning,
computed tomography.
Occasionally we also generate
specimens of skeletons.
So here I have an example.
This is,
you may guess,
a Flamingo.
And in this case,
the skeleton is disarticulated,
means every bone detached
and available for making measurements
and photograph individually.
In addition for the exhibits,
we have sometimes prepare
skeletons that are articulated.
And in this case here,
there is a Great Auk skeleton,
put together anatomically correctly.
And besides these,
there's a big collection
of nests and eggs.
So here's an example of an egg set.
So, nicely padded.
And these are not your entire eggs,
but emptied eggs.
So you can see these holes
in the equatorial part of the egg.
And this simply is an egg shell
that is measurable and can be studied.
And nests.
We have also a large collection of nests,
and here's an example of an Oriole nest
suspended from a fork
like a little hammock.
And if you maybe zoom in,
you can perhaps see that there is
a lot of fishing line embedded into it.
There is even a hook dangling,
right here.
So this bird appropriated the material
that found somewhere along the river.
And in addition to all of this,
we also preserve tissue samples.
This is just an empty tube to show you,
but for every single specimen
we collect these days,
we preserve a little
piece of muscle tissue
or some other tissue.
And these are all stored in our
liquid nitrogen vapor frozen facility.
And what you see on the exhibits
is just the tip of the iceberg.
So here behind me,
you have a little example,
some examples of mammals and birds
that were at some point
in the Peabody exhibits,
but now they're here in storage
waiting for another opportunity.
(upbeat music)